>> Laura: IF THAT WOULD TURN
TO FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND
ARROYO.
THIS SEGMENT IS ALL ABOUT THE
DANGERS OF PUTTING ON A SHOW.
>> STARTING AT THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT DINNER, THE ANNUAL
WEEKEND OF JOURNALISTIC
SELF-CONGRATULATION JAM WITH
POLITICIANS AND ASSORTED
CELEBRITIES BUT IT TURNS OUT
TREVOR NOAH'S COMMENTS PROVED
PROPHETIC LISTEN.
>> IS MY GREAT HONOR TO BE
SPEAKING AT THIS MOST
DISTINGUISHED SUPER SPREADER
EVENT.
NO FOR REAL WHAT WE DOING HERE
LET'S BE HONEST WILL BE DOING?
QUESTION RECOLLECTED NONE OF YOU
LEARNED ANYTHING FROM THE
GRIDIRON DINNER?
I DO AND IF YOU WOULD READ ANY
OF YOUR OWN NEWSPAPERS?
>> APPARENTLY NOT CNN IS
REPORTING THAT MULTIPLE
CORRESPONDENCE THEATER ATTENDEES
FROM VARIOUS OPERATIONS ARE
TESTING POSITIVE FOR WITH THE
MAIL DESCRIBES AS A SUPER
SPREADER.
BY THE WAY SAME-DAY TESTING AND
MULTIPLE BOOSTERS NEEDED FOR
ADMISSION WITH A TEDIOUS AFFAIR
REVEALED MORE THAN THE
PARTICIPANTS I THINK THEY TEMPER
THE TEST IS OFF.
>> IS THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT DINNER WITH
APPEARANCES FROM CECILIA VEGA,
THE PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES.
♪ ♪
>> LAURA YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP
OVER AT CNN THEY CONVENED WHAT
APPEARED TO BE THE ENTIRE U.N.
SECURITY COUNCIL TO SELL THIS
THING COMPLETE WITH A RED CARPET
REPORTER WHAT ARE THEY WEARING?
>> I SAW KIM KARDASHIAN, PETE
DAVIDSON, CAITLYN JENNER WAS
HERE IF YOU'RE A FAN OF
SUCCESSION ONE OF THE I'M
BLANKING ON, JERRY ON
SUCCESSION.
>> DOES ANYONE THINK THAT ANYONE
WHO IS TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
CARRY IF JERRY FROM SUCCESSION
IS DINING WITH THESE PAMPERED
JOURNALISTS?
ALL OF WHOM BY THE WAY PHIL
PEOPLE IN VARIOUS WAYS, THEY
SUPPRESS STORIES THAT IN LIKE,
THESE SPENT LIKE DRUNKEN
KARDASHIANS AND I WOULD
HUNDRED --
WHY ARE THEY CONGRATULATING EACH
OTHER?
>> Laura: WHEN THEY GATHER IN
A HOUSE OF WORSHIP AND AN NCAA
FOOTBALL GAME, HAVE WE ENTERED A
DIFFERENT STAGE OF THE PANDEMIC
IS AT THE END OF THE PANDEMIC?
OR ARE WE JUST GETTING GOING
RAMEN IT'S ALWAYS HARD TO FIGURE
IT OUT.
>> TYPICAL OF ABOUT AWARD SHOW
THIS WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS'
DINNER HAS A LAME SKIT WITH
JAMES CORDEN AND THE PRESIDENT
IN THE PRESENT APPEARED TO HAVE
NO IDEA WHO JAMES CORDEN WAS,
JOE BIDEN HAD NO IDEA THAT HE
WAS READING A JOKE FROM THE
TELEPROMPTER.
>> JUST IMAGINE MY PREDECESSOR
CAME TO THIS DINNER THIS YEAR
NOW THAT WILLIE HAVE BEEN A REAL
COUP.
[LAUGHS]
LITTLE TOUGH ON?
>> Laura: I'M SO SAD, SO SAD.
TREVOR NOAH BARELY LAID A HAND
ON JOE BIDEN WE WATCH THE CLIPS
HE DID MAKE THIS IMPORTANT
OBSERVATION THOUGH.
>> YOU GUYS HAVE INTEGRITY, YOU
WOULD NEVER ALLOW PERSONAL
CONNECTIONS TO AFFECT YOUR
ABILITY TO BE GOOD JOURNALISTS.
IT IS NOT RICE CHRIS CUOMO?
WHERE IS HE BY THE WAY IS HE
HERE?
>> HE WAS PROBABLY WATCHING AT
JEFF ZUCKER'S HOUSE.
IS A FEW THINGS THAT TREVOR GOT
WRONG INCLUDING WHO WAS IN
ATTENDANCE.
HE REPEATEDLY CLAIMED
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS WAS
THERE AND CALLED THE SANTAS OUT
THE NEXT DAY HE HELD A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
>> I WOULD NEVER ATTEND THAT
I'VE NO INTEREST IN THAT SO HERE
THEY ARE SAYING HOW IMPORTANT
THEY ARE THERE SOMEHOW THESE
PARAGONS OF TRUTH AND HOW THEY
ARE LYING ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
IS READILY VERIFIABLE.
>> AND AGAIN THIS IS WHY THEIR
RATINGS AND TRUSTWORTHINESS
AMONG THE PUBLIC IS AT AN
ALL-TIME LOW AMONG 46 COUNTRIES
WE HAVE THE LOWEST IMMEDIATE
TRUST.
OH, AND TREVOR NOAH RECOGNIZED
YOU FROM THE PODIUM AS WELL
LAURA.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT FOX PRIME
TIME, SEAN HANNITY,
LAURA INGRAHAM, LAURA INGRAHAM
WOW.
>> OKAY SO NAME MATT FOR MEDIA
MATTERS TWEETED THAT
LAURA INGRAHAM WAS ASKED THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT DINNER
SO TELL ME LAURA I WAS THE FOOD,
DID YOU SEE PETE DAVIDSON WHAT
HAPPENED?
>> Laura: I WAS WITH YOU AND
ALL OF OUR FRIENDS AT THE
NEW ORLEANS JAZZ FEST.
THERE WE ARE.
OVERALL THERE.
I THINK THAT WAS AT THE WHO WHEN
THE WHO PERFORMED.
RINGO STARR SON ON THE DRUMS.
THAT WAS ACTUALLY A FUN TIME
THAT WHOLE DAY.
I WAS NOT AT THE WHITE HOUSE
DINNER.
>> AND AS LONG OR TARDY ABOUT
DANGERS OF PUTTING ON A SHOW,
I'M SURE THAT YOU THINK IT'S
VERY SAFE AND SECURE SINCE
UNITED STATES HAS SENT ITS BEST
AND BRIGHTEST TO SUPPORT
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY.
♪ ♪
>> POUR NANCY PELOSI SHIMA
STRIKE FEAR IN THE RUSSIANS?
I'M SURE THAT THEY'RE IN A PULL
BACK THE TANKS AFTER SEEING THAT
ADAM SCHIFF IS ALSO ON THE
SCENE.
PERIOD UKRAINE'S INFLATION RATE
JUST ROSE TWO POINTS AND ITS
BORDERS ARE PROBABLY 50%.
>> Laura: THEY SHOULD SWITCH
COSTUMES, HE SHOULD AWARD THE
PANTSUIT AND NANCY PELOSI
SHOULD'VE WARNED THAT.
WHAT NANCY SAID TO THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT SHOULD GIVE EVERYONE
SOME PAUSE RAYMOND.
>> OUR COMMITMENT IS TO BE THERE
FOR YOU UNTIL THE FIGHTING IS
DONE.
>> UNTIL THE FIGHT IS DONE?
>> Laura: THEY VOTED ON A WAR
RESOLUTION TO DECLARE WAR IN
CONGRESS BUT I THINK THEY
HAVEN'T DONE THAT.
>> UNTIL THE END.
>> Laura: RAYMOND SO SAD WE
MISSED THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER.
>> NOT ME.
[LAUGH